el poderoso mundo de las mujeres si las
mujeres podemos dar vida que no podemos
hacer hoy quiero que reflexionemos sobre
el empoderamiento de las mujeres soy
esposa madre de cuatro hijos abuelita
hermana amiga y ejecutiva compartamos un
poco los mitos y retos que enfrentamos
las mujeres al emprender este camino
hace algunos años el rol de la mujer se
limitaba a ser esposa y madre había
estereotipos culturales
y por lo tanto juicios sobre aquellas
mujeres
kerr estábamos en ese rol
eso hizo que algunas mujeres no se
atrevieran que otras nos atreviéramos y
dudáramos sentíamos miedo sentíamos
culpa nos cuestionábamos si estaríamos
sacrificando nuestro más preciado tesoro
la familia
las empresas representadas por sus
líderes cuestionaban la dedicación que
una mujer podría dar a su trabajo
considerando su rol de madre nos
preguntaban usted tiene hijos quien se
los cuidan puede trabajar fuera de
horario
trabajamos ardua e incansablemente para
demostrar nuestras capacidades
cuestionadas trabajamos para ser
escuchadas para que nuestras ideas
fueran respetadas y luego aceptadas
recuerdo una anécdota una vez que fuimos
a una negociación a un banco
cuando entramos nos presentamos ellos
entregaron su tarjeta de presentación a
todos menos a mí yo era la única mujer
la reunión avanzó y cuando llegó el
momento de la negociación
mi jefe dijo los dejo con tere que es la
gerente responsable tremenda sorpresa
cuando pensaba que quería compartir
venían a mi mente ejemplos como estos
y me di cuenta que cada uno de ellos me
retaba a ser mejor persona y mejor
profesional al final nosotros decidimos
cómo nos vivimos la vida
personalmente creo que al involucrarse
la mujer en el rol laboral de la
sociedad la sociedad ganó y ganó mucho
porque las mujeres empezamos a compartir
tareas que eran solo de mujeres
pedíamos ayuda con las tareas del lugar
con las tareas de nuestros hijos
esto hizo que el rol de padre también se
transformara y pasara de ser un padre
proveedor a ser un padre accesible
cercano comunicativo y amoroso
quién día a día iba valorando este doble
rol que teníamos las mujeres volviendo a
su mirada más comprensiva y colaboradora
las empresas las empresas que
involucraron a las mujeres en roles de
liderazgo también ganaron porque
integraron a la visión de negocio una
visión de un mundo que no conocían
integraron una fuerza laboral
perseverante resiliente intuitiva
y comprometida
integrarme al mundo ejecutivo rompía un
esquema de muchas décadas y tradiciones
sacudía una sociedad tradicional
era hacer equipo
era dejar huella crear historia
trascender era hacer un equilibrio entre
lo emocional y lo racional
entre el hacer y el ser
era inspirar un mundo de oportunidades
era predicar con el ejemplo con valores
con tenacidad y respeto
pero qué significa empoderarnos
qué quiero decir con el poderoso mundo
de las mujeres
empoderarnos significa identificar
nuestras fortalezas conectarnos con
ellas saber qué es aquello que nos hace
diferente
confiar en nosotros conocer los anhelos
de nuestro corazón
conocer nuestros valores y saber que
estamos dispuestas a hacer para alcanzar
nuestros sueños
qué quiero decir con conectarnos con
nuestra fuerza interior
conectarnos con nuestra fuerza interior
es a quitar nuestra mente no dejar que
nuestros pensamientos nos boicoteen
es mantener una mente positiva
estamos empoderados cuando logramos ver
en la adversidad la oportunidad
cuando tomamos total responsabilidad de
nuestras decisiones y de nuestras
acciones
cuando nos volvemos protagonistas de
nuestra vida
reto siempre habrá y podremos
enfrentarlos cuando realmente estamos
conectados con nuestro poder interior
con nuestras capacidades
qué significa trabajar desde adentro
cambiamos nuestro interior y nuestro
mundo cambiará
convirtamos las adversidades en
oportunidades cambiemos nuestro dolor
por aprendizaje
nada ni nadie tiene poder más que el que
yo le otorgo
esta frase es muy poderosa
y quisiera que nos detengamos a pensar
que quiere decir nada ni nadie tiene
poder más que el que yo le otorgo el
otro día conversando me preguntaban y
qué hago si me encuentro con alguien que
tiene más poder que yo
y me di cuenta que es importante
diferenciar entre mayor jerarquía que
mayor poder con los que nosotros
puede ser un jefe puede ser una
autoridad
y probablemente tenga más jerarquía pero
no va a tener mayor poder sobre nosotros
si nosotros no se lo entregamos
aquí hemos empoderado en vez de
empoderarnos a nosotros mismos
la motivación también es muy importante
entender cuál es nuestra motivación
que eso es clarísimo porque será lo que
nos ayude cuando dudemos cuando nosotros
entendemos que me motiva a alcanzar un
sueño
qué es la meta que es el valor que hay
detrás del sueño y eso será lo que nos
fortalezca cuando dudemos y lo que nos
ayude a levantarnos cuando nos
tropecemos recordemos que el boxeador no
pierde la batalla cuando se cae la
pierde cuando decide no levantarse
también es sumamente importante entender
cuáles son nuestros mayores temores
qué es aquello que sabotea nuestro
pensamiento
son fundados o infundados son creados
por nuestra mente anticipada con todo lo
que podría suceder
que nos agobia y nos paraliza
podría seguir imaginando me
que nos decimos a nosotras mismas bueno
quizás algunas escuchen y digan
seguramente tuvo más oportunidades o
seguramente su mundo y su realidad es
diferente pero no esas son las
justificaciones que nos damos a nosotras
mismas cuando no creemos que algo
verdaderamente maravilloso está para
cada uno de nosotros
alcanzarlo disfrutarlo detenernos a
saborearlo depende de cada uno de
nosotros
defender con ahínco nuestros sueños
sin detenernos es perseverancia
en algunas ocasiones escucho
ideologías para defender la igualdad de
género
a mí me gusta pensar que somos
diferentes y que podemos construir un
gran mundo con las fortalezas de cada
género
no creo en desgastarnos
debatiendo que somos iguales para mí no
somos iguales
somos diferentes pero podemos luchar
luchar con ahínco por nuestros sueños
por nuestros anhelos
podemos defender la equidad
podemos generar nuestras oportunidades
si queremos respeto pensemos que tanto
nos respetamos a nosotras mismas
y respetándonos que seremos respetadas
escuchando los que seremos escuchadas
indistintamente de la sociedad en la que
naciste
del entorno en el que gire tu mundo
lo que logré es crear
las oportunidades no vendrán del mundo
exterior vendrán de todo aquello que tú
creas que realmente es posible para ti
vendrán de todo aquello que tú creas y
que esté dispuesta a alcanzar por ti
no dejemos nuestros sueños y nuestras
metas en manos de otras personas
hay algunos mitos que me gustaría mucho
compartir y que juntas empoderadas
podemos desafiar
que a las mujeres tenemos menos
oportunidades
se los cambió por realmente te has
atrevido a buscar y a generar tus
oportunidades
que hay algunas profesiones que no son
para mujeres
se los cambió pues realmente sabes qué
es lo que verdaderamente te apasiona y
sabes cuáles son tus fortalezas y sabes
cuáles son los anhelos de tu corazón y
estás dispuesto a luchar para
alcanzarlos
miren a mi mente algunas profesiones
como la ingeniería y la aviación eran
sólo para hombres hasta que hubo algunas
mujeres que se atrevieron a ir detrás de
sus sueños creando nuevas realidades
para ellas y para las futuras
generaciones
que a las mujeres nos pagan un salario
menor
te lo cambio realmente sabes cuánto vale
tu trabajo está dispuesta a pedirlo
y si lo has pedido y no lo has
conseguido qué vas a hacer al respecto
que no se puede hacer
madre y profesional a la vez
pues como madre de cuatro hijos debo
decirles que si se puede
y que juntos lo logramos porque nuestros
proyectos se vuelven proyectos de
familia y nuestros hijos ven valores más
allá
predicamos con el ejemplo y les
enseñamos a que se puede ser feliz que
se puede soñar y que se puede alcanzar
todos los anhelos de tu corazón
poner límites es cuestión de dignidad
así sea decirnos a nosotros mismos basta
este miedo se acaba hoy
gratitud
me llenó de profunda gratitud al
recordar a aquellos hombres que me han
acompañado en este camino aquellos
hombres que han creído en mí
que creyeron en mis sueños que me
empoderaron y que me apoyaron
mi padre mi esposo mi hijo algunos jefes
compañeros
porque también ellos retaron sus roles
retaron sus creencias
se enfrentaron a una sociedad con mitos
cada uno con sus creencias
y por qué no decirlo retaron su
comodidad
y no puedo dejar de agradecer también a
todos aquellos hombres que no me
apoyaron
porque aún sin darse cuenta me estaban
fortaleciendo me estaban retando a dar
lo mejor de mí
hubo enseñanzas que atesoro profundo
profundamente en mi corazón
y quizás la más importante fue aprender
a vivir con mis decisiones
a no buscar una aceptación externa
a buscar y conectarme con mi paz
interior
honró con gratitud esas personas que me
ayudaron a crecer gracias
a veces encontramos gente que no tiene
claridad de su propósito
de sus sueños
de su vida
yo los quiero invitar
a vivir la vida que han soñado
a no delegar una tarea tan importante
como es soñar y alcanzar nuestros sueños
y vivir con valores y trascendencia
resignarnos a vivir la vida de otras
personas no se vale
buscar justificaciones buscar excusas
victimizarnos no nos hace grandes pero
sobre todo no nos hace plenas
seamos arquitectos de nuestra vida
y pensemos qué es lo que realmente
queremos construir en ellas
atrévete atrévete hoy el día puede ser
hoy la hora es ahora
diseña tu vida cual pintor que detalla
su cuadro y cual arquitecto que diseña
su casa y pensemos como estamos en las
diferentes áreas de nuestra vida
en la salud
en el gozo cuánto tiempo de la semana
dedicamos a no hacer nada
confundimos el hacer con el ser
nos llenamos día a día de actividades
para estar muy ocupados y ser muy
importantes pero nos olvidamos de
nosotros
diseña y atrévete a tener la vida que
siempre has querido tener tu vida merece
ser vivida con pasión y propósito y que
el día que ya no estemos
nos recuerden diciendo quien no ha
muerto porque su legado vive en nosotros
y responsabilidad social
cuánto tiempo dedicamos a retribuirle a
la sociedad un poquito de lo mucho que
tenemos
nuestras finanzas
realmente merece la pena y si algunas de
estas preguntas
no tienen las respuestas que realmente
quisieras escuchar
nunca es tarde para detenerte a diseñar
indistintamente de la etapa en la que te
encuentres
diseña tu vida
que no sea a la suerte o el accidente lo
que quieras
una mujer merece ser fiel a su propia
naturaleza
merece crecer integralmente ser plena y
vivir alcanzando sus sueños al final
alcanzar los sueños no es un tema de
género es un tema de propósito de coraje
y de claridad de perseverancia
es un tema de empoderamiento de cada uno
de nosotros